what can you tell people though the
status of like what's going on because
I've heard that DC's hard at work
developing Superman sequel and true
swear it sucks I'm having a lot of
conversations behind the scene is it
certainly and we will hopefully be
having a conversation for other people
who are also behind the scenes to make
things start happening it is very much
in my desire to do a Man of Steel to
direct sequel to Anna Steel sure and
there's a whole bunch of Superman story
that I want to tell it's a whole style
of Superman's character but I'm very
keen to tell and I'm looking forward to
the opportunity I might be talking again
about extending her contract again I
actually I honestly honestly don't know
anything that there's a possibility
there I forget what's in my car I forget
if I'm actually I'm still I think you
always to do one more you have no one
more picture regardless regardless of
that or not a story that I would love
and if that stuff starts to happen and
with exciting filmmakers like close
relationships with
and regardless I'm gonna have one more
or not I'm doing sure is I want to tell
them all the secrets hey everybody it's
Charlie this is gonna be my Man of Steel
2 video that had CinemaCon this past
weekend so there was Aquaman footage
that they showed off there was a bunch
of stuff from a bunch of different
studios but I just wanted to focus on
Superman Man of Steel 2 stuff because
that's still kind of up in the air even
though we're all expecting them to make
it in the relatively near future if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I love the way that he ends that
interview to wear like the interviewer
collider frosty of Collider is basically
talking to him about his contract status
with Warner Brothers and he says
regardless of what's going on I need me
to make another Superman movie as much
as you the audience needs me to make
another Superman movie there's just so
much more story to tell
he actually specifically calls out a
direct sequel to Man of Steel not so
much a sequel to Justice League which is
an interesting idea like where would
they pick up in the timeline but if you
guys didn't know the reason why he's
giving all these Superman interviews is
because he's at CinemaCon this week as
I'm posting this video to promote
Mission Impossible 6 with Tom Cruise
most of the people that were there
agreed that Mission Impossible 6 won the
convention with their presentation if
you don't know what CinemaCon is it's
kind of like a Comic Con for business
professionals in the entertainment
industry in the theatre industry so you
have exhibitionists that own theaters
that are going to see what movies the
studio's are gonna be releasing so as
part of that they show off a ton of
footage that they don't necessarily
release publicly they dropped an Aquaman
trailer James Wan said that the effects
weren't even close to being finished so
I don't think they're gonna be dropping
it publicly anytime soon but when Henry
Cavill was giving all of these Superman
interviews it was kind of the same
version of the same interview so when he
said that we're talking to people who
were talking to other people that are
talking to the people in power he was
saying yeah we're gonna do it but it
gives you an idea for the chain of
custody that these big movies go through
when they get greenlit but then you have
to actually jump through those hoops
like who's gonna direct it who's gonna
write it what's the script going to be
what story are you going to tell when
are we going to release it it sounds
like
he actually wants to do something with
christopher mcquarrie who just got done
directing Mission Impossible 6 which
will get you a little more excited once
you see Mission Impossible 6 and some of
the crazy action scenes that they pull
off and that he would actually be a
pretty solid pick for a Superman movie
henry cavill also said that while they
were filming Mission Impossible 6 he and
Christopher McQuarrie talked about
teaming up for a Superman movie Henry
Cavill knows what it would be like we
you know we had a lot of time hanging
out unsaid and and Henry's a huge fan of
Superman and I can't help but but talk
story with people so he told me his take
on men on Superman and I thought it was
really great and I gave him my two cents
the tweet you're referring to if
somebody asked would you do it and I
said hey they know where to find me
nobody's asked but you know so that
doesn't mean that he's automatically
going to do it but when you have a
director that's that big and that's
successful and has this big of a movie
coming out like Henry Cavill is pretty
awesome during Mission Impossible 6
Christopher McQuarrie is probably gonna
walk away with people thinking that it
was a successful film so it makes a lot
easier for a studio like Warner Brothers
to say okay you know we feel comfortable
giving you one hundred and fifty two
hundred million dollars to do another
Superman film knowing that you have all
these successful films behind you you
have a solid idea and it fits within the
new tone of films that we're doing so
like Wonder Woman 2 is already set to go
they confirmed that it's gonna be set
during the 80s we know that Matt Reeves
is gonna do his Batman film we have the
Shazam movie coming out they even showed
off footage from the shows a movie at
CinemaCon but it was even more
unfinished than the Aquaman footage so I
think it's gonna be a long time before
we see a Shazam teaser but you have to
imagine that whatever the next Superman
movie is going to be we'll call it man
of tomorrow for now it's gonna kind of
fit with the other films that they're
releasing so that however this next
Superman film is connected or
disconnected from the other films that
are being made it still fits totally
with the other films and you know I
think the idea is that Wonder Woman
totally is a lot like Superman totally
patty Jenkins spent a lot of time when
the first Wonder Woman movie came out
talking about how she was going for
Superman's the movie Richard Donner
Superman so literally the tone of Wonder
Woman flows from Superman so regardless
of what the story for Man of Steel 2 is
you kind of have an idea too
leave for what they might be going for
so hopefully that gives you a pretty
good idea of what's going on behind the
scenes but just to explain that all
command footage that they showed up it
was basically just a couple different
action scenes he gets into a big fight
with Black Manta they're on a submarine
so there wasn't a whole lot of story in
the footage that they showed off when
they do actually drop what will probably
be a Comic Con trailer in a couple
months that will be more of a story
based trailer like you get a sense for
who the characters are Black Manta ocean
master mera what the characters gonna
feel like compared to the other times
that we've seen him so far because just
like Henry Cavill was doing all these
interviews talking about Superman Jason
Momoa was there talking about the
Aquaman character Amber Heard was there
talking about Meera to talk how much of
you did you inject you want to do make
Aquaman different than what you just
described and so that's all we set out
to do and now we're gonna know why he
was that way so we're in the origin
story we're gonna find out why he wasn't
loved in Atlantis and why it wasn't
living on the surface and now he has
something that's beautiful that can help
the world and like knowing it was
something that can you have to offer to
this world circling back around for a
Man of Steel to though let me know what
do you think about the idea of
Christopher McQuarrie Mission Impossible
Man directing a Man of Steel movie
probably the best thing you could do
though is just go see Mission Impossible
6 and see what that movie feels like I
mean see Henry Cavill and it make all
the moustache jokes that you want but
then imagine that guy doing a Man of
Steel movie but in Superman related news
I haven't done a video about it but they
just introduced the doomsday character a
comic book accurate doomsday on the
Krypton TV show he'll and Zod sigil
superimposed on each other I think our
families put this fall
[Music]
so if you haven't been watching that I
would recommend that you check it out
they also introduced general Zod's so
there's just like a lot of big Superman
comic book stuff happening on that TV
show but what'll happen tonight is I'm
posting New Avengers infinity Wars
there's gonna be a lot of infinity war
dropping in the next couple of days so
everybody just brace yourself it's gonna
be awesome
click here for my non-spoilery infinity
war review and click here for brand new
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight